[Music]
so if you're new to connect connect is
an enterprise publishing platform for
static and dynamic content that you're
creating with our so that can include
documents presentations dashboards and
shiny applications and basically
anything that you're producing an AR it
is an on-premises application so you run
this on your own server behind a
firewall if you want and you're going to
host it you know on your own equipment
there and the goal is really around
sharing data science artifacts that you
produced inside your organization so if
this is new to you I would recommend
actually that you check out the
introductory webinar that Bill
referenced a moment ago so we recorded
this two weeks ago the recording is
available online as are the slides and I
recommend that you start there because
we're going to be building on some of
the foundation that we laid a couple
weeks ago so if you are new to connect
you might want to start there before you
jump into some of these more advanced
topics but without any further ado let's
go ahead and start on 10th that we want
to cover today so my goal for today is
really just to give you pointers to the
different tidbits that that I think are
important for you to know if you're
going to be managing our studio konnekt
in a production environment and so I
won't go into too much of depth about a
whole lot of these but but really I just
kind of want to give you links and
pointers to the different things that
you might be interested in if you are
responsible for managing a production
environment with our studio konnekt so
pardon me if I'm kind of flying through
some of these topics but feel free to
ask questions and we can come back and
do a little more detail and some of
these things later or you know just
check out the links once we post them
online and and you know hopefully canned
you can kind of find the information
that you need there with the links that
I provide so today I want to cover first
of all user management then secondly the
management of resources on the server
and then lastly we'll talk a little bit
about kind of the system management and
system security implications for the
server so let's dive into user
management to get started so we covered
this a bit last time so I won't belabor
this but we have three different user
roles on the system the first is an
admin user who has all privileges on the
server and they can access and kind of
manage anything that they need to
but irregular actions are audited and
I'll dive into what that means here in a
moment
below that there would be a publisher
who's someone that can upload or publish
content onto the server and then lastly
there's a viewer who's just a consumer
of content and can't offer content that
gets executed on the server so let's
talk a little bit about what the
experience of a connect administrator
looks like so first of all they have
access to special admin only actions and
so for instance this includes the admin
tab so if you're an admin on the user
you're able to access certain pages
within the dashboards that other users
aren't able to manage that shows you
things like metrics you're able to
manage users and things like that
and then lastly you're able to customize
some application settings that other
users aren't able to so you can define
vanity URLs for an application you can
customize the run as argument for an
application and I'll show you what all
this means here in just a moment but the
trick is that you don't get everything
for freeze and Edmund and so some of
these things are going to be able to
just hop on and start changing other
things you're going to actually have to
go out of your way to explicitly grant
yourself permission to things that you
otherwise wouldn't have had permission
to so let's I think that's probably best
covered by just an example so let's
let's look at an example of this so
first of all this is me logged in as an
admin user on connect and so you can see
that first of all I had this admin tap
he said that takes me first and foremost
to this metrics page where I'm able to
view information about the CPU and RAM
usage across the server I also have an
audit logs page here where I can view
kind of different changes that have been
taking place on the server recently
and then lastly when I dive into
particular content even though this is
not authored by me this is authored by
someone else and I don't have particular
person settings for this content so for
instance here I can define a vanity URL
let's take a look at kind of a more rich
document here so in this case we have a
schedule I as an administrator even
though I don't have special privileges
on this document I can go in and
customize the schedule for this content
I can you know define a vanity URL
change the run as user etc so I even
have free privileges to be able to do
some of these things however if you look
at something like a document here that's
private so here I'm logged in as a
different user this is the publisher
user and you can see that I for this
content here I've defined it to only be
visible to myself so this means that the
admin user should not freely have access
to this content this is sensitive
content that the admin shouldn't be able
to see and indeed if I go is the admin
and I go to look at that content this is
the view that I get so you can see that
I'm still able to manage the settings
for that content here but I do not have
free access to be able to view that
content and so this is kind of what
we're talking about when we say the
admin has the privileges to do whatever
they need to do on the server but they
don't get everything for free so I am
NOT able to view this content although I
can go in and I can add myself as a
publisher or the viewer because I'm able
to manage the settings on this conte and
at that point I would be able to view
the content and so the trick here is
that all of this though is managed when
you make these explicit actions to add
or remove yourself to a particular bit
of content all of those actions are
going to be captured in the audit log
that I referenced earlier so when I go
look at the auto log you can see here
that the admin user assigned themselves
as an owner as a collaborator on this
app and then they were moved in tells us
an owner is a collaborator on SAP so now
while I am able to do everything and
navigate whatever I need to
cover to be able to manage the server
anytime I take those explicit options of
kind of going out of my way to take
special privileges on an application
that's gonna be captured in the audit
log and that's kind of the balance that
we try to strike here with an admin
lastly if you've missed this at our
latest release the 1.44 one release we
also do have the ability to download the
source code for for content and again
that's only available to users that are
that are explicitly granted collaborator
privileges so I as an admin do not get
free access to source codes published on
the server however if I add myself as a
collaborator then I am able to download
the source code for an application so
this is kind of the balance that we
tried to strike with an admin but I
think it's important if you're going to
be managing a connect server in
production that you kind of understand
what the privileges of an admin actually
encapsulate and what you get for free
and what you don't so next we'll just
kind of move on and a lot of these
things I'm just going to cover in
rapid-fire but the next one that I
wanted to cover is the default user role
so this is a setting that's managed in
the authorization section and they do
the default user role setting and this
is basically the roles that fresh users
should take when they sign on to the
server the default right now is
publisher which means that when a user
signs up on your server or when they you
know login using whatever authentication
protocol you're using that user is going
to become a publisher on the server
they're going to have access to publish
new source code if you want to change
that if you want to limit that so that
default so that new users coming into
the server are just viewers you can
change this configuration setting here
and make that a viewer and this is
actually subject to change we've
considered actually making the default
viewer and so in which case if you
wanted the default to be publisher you
could of course override that here
another tool that you should be aware of
if you're managing Connect is the user
manager command-line interface and this
is a root only command-line interface
that allows you to interact with Connect
in kind of a batch way and so right now
there's kind of a limited subset of what
you can do with this command but we
envision this growing over time to
capture more of the interactions that
you might want to take within Connect so
right now one restriction is that the
server actually does need to be stopped
and order for you for you to use the the
command-line interface here and that
that's a restriction that may be listed
here in the coming months but right now
you can access the tool at this location
the opto studio konnekt bin user manager
and then you can run commands such as
lists to list all the users in the
server you know an alter to
a user for instance promoting a viewer
to a publisher or promoting a publisher
to an admin user and you can also
actually dump the audit logs even in the
CSV format here so if you wanted to
navigate and browse the audit logs on
your own time and/or using your own
tooling you could do that here I'm using
this user manager tool so something you
should be aware of and you can view all
the documents in the admin guide for
what different inputs are available in
this command next there's an idea of
user locking in the server that you
should be familiar with so so as of the
time of this recording in early 2017 we
don't have a notion of user deletion and
the reason for that is that there are a
lot of open questions around what should
you do with a user who's deleted what
should you do with their content should
you migrate it to another user should
you keep it alive on the server or
should you get rid of it
so until we settle some of those
questions right now we've kind of
settled on this compromise if user
locking so if you for instance have an
employee leave the company and you don't
want them to have access to the server
anymore you can lock their account which
forbids any further login or interaction
on the system they can't publish updates
or new content to the server and they
also don't count against your license so
they're not going to count as a as a
named user and they're not gonna take up
a seed for your license when they're
locked and also you should be aware that
you can rename users and so if your goal
is just to get rid of a user who's
taking up a username that you want you
can certainly just change the user name
for that user and lock it and then
create a new user account with the
username that you desire so that's a bit
about user management and we can
transition into resource management now
which is a bit more of a complex topic
so one of the most common questions that
we get around Connect is the idea of
resource budgeting or how large should
my server be and the problem or the
difficulty in answering this question is
that the the requirements here almost
depend entirely on what your users are
deploying so if you just have a couple
of simple documents that you know a
couple of simple dashboards that are
updated once a day that people are going
to access on your connect server you
could probably get away with some
running this on you know something like
very very small even you know a
Raspberry Pi could probably handle that
kind of workload however if you're doing
you know very intensive shiny
applications that are doing you know
genomic analysis on multiple gigabytes
of data then your server requirements
you can
much much larger so ideally if you if
you have the luxury of being in a
virtualized environment where you can
kind of scale up or down a server that
would probably be your best bet but
otherwise if not you can kind of run a
proof of concept and see what the
hardware requirements are given the
applications and the types of work that
your that your users are publishing to
the server and that's really the best
way to kind of get a feel for what your
requirements should be in terms of
hardware for the server so in terms of
the philosophy of Connect on demand
requests are largely what we're
servicing when requests are coming in
and those are just going to be service
best effort so you know as a request
comes in for a shiny application we're
going to do our best to spin up that's
about that shiny application hope that
there's enough memory available on the
server so but there are some knobs and
some tuning that you can do to cap the
resource requirements available to
particular applications or different
different use cases so first of all the
around shiny there's there's a notion of
shiny scaling so you can scale shiny
applications and connect to multiple
processes so if you're not aware our is
single threaded and connect can actually
load balanced a particular application
across multiple independent our
processes running that at that same
application and so this is what's
managed here in the performance tab on a
shiny app so as an admin you can go in
and you can override particular
performance settings for an application
and set for instance the number of max
processes how many processes you know
under the heaviest load that you might
be willing to run for this application
and then down at the bottom here you can
see kind of some of the scaling
parameters around how many connections
should be supported for process and then
the load factor is basically how quickly
do you want to ramp up from the minimum
number of processes to the maximum
number of processes as load increases
the minimum number of processes as the
name implies is the is going to
guarantee that in processes are running
for this application at all times the
right answer for this for almost all
applications is zero however if you have
an application that takes a really long
time to start up and you don't want to
use are hitting it having to wait
multiple seconds or even minutes for the
show